I went live, live.
Alright, now you can swap.
Yay!
We're going straight in.
I had no intro, I just went straight in.
You just opened up all the games.
Yep, that's it.
That's usually what happens in Collab.
I just go straight in at that point.
I've stopped putting an intro.
It reminds me of when I was a Camelist streamer and I would literally hit the go live button on the game title screen and there was no fanfare whatsoever.
Yeah, we're just here.
It's time to give.
Yeah, the reason why Snuffy sounds like she's dead inside is that we literally woke her up from a Discord call.
Don't need to be rude, chat.
Some people think it's attractive.
The reason Snuffy has sexy morning voice is because...
Oh, and those some people is Lime.
Oh yeah, Snuffy, I need you to appear online for like one second.
Oh yeah, yeah, okay.
So I can get you in the lobby.
After months of staying offline, I risk it all for this.
Just for Devour.
Don't know you're alive now.
You're now back on the grid.
It happens to me too.
I just hide offline forever and then people are like, no, you have to be online.
It's like, but...
You have to be online.
That's why I'm hosting, so I don't have to be online.
But then no one will know when I'm playing my porn games if I'm not online.
You don't even have massage.
What is it?
Orc massage.
That's not the only game.
But it's the game.
That's your game.
That's not my game, it's the people's game.
It's okay, Snuffy, neither have I.
We just spent the last ten minutes finding stupid things to put on our characters.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We literally spent money.
What?
I didn't even see that.
I got scammed because I'm...
Welcome to the default redhead.
What?
You guys look like my cool dads.
And I look like I'm a Greek.
And you look like my pet rat.
Do you like my pet rat over here?
Our pet rats.
Our gay dads and our twin daughters.
The gay dads and our twin daughters.
The gay dads and then we got the hipster daughter over here.
And then the one that turned to religion apparently.
Fives, you look like you should be in an Irish pub.
You look like a Canadian, eh?
Yeah, and then we all moved to Canada.
Wait, you got a rat?
Yeah!
Yeah, she had a rat too.
She looks after her cooler father.
Okay, you can not look at me and say that I'm not the cooler father.
Look at me!
Yes, you can!
I'm literally a fucking ex-Hollywood star!
What do you mean an ex-Hollywood star?
It says, Sam, washed up Hollywood star.
Loves John Wayne movies and Satan.
Hates most people.
Wait, we have characters?
Wait, you look Canadian.
What is your...
No one cares about an ex-Hollywood star.
Oh, you care.
You fucking are the other gay dad.
Okay, hold on.
I might join a cult one day instead of going into work.
I'm a competitive eating champion!
Oh yeah, that's why they said I'm the cooler dad.
I need to put my outfit back on.
Is this pre-cult or post-cult?
This is post-cult and I own the cult.
Co-own the cult and these are the two children we had that we did not steal into our family.
That we didn't indoctrinate into the cult and brainwash them.
I don't look anything like you.
So, basically, this is what Tom Cruise wishes you.
Oh my god.
I don't think he wants to be a washed up actor.
That's true, other than that part.
Okay, I bought my outfit so I don't feel like such a freaking plebian with you guys.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh,
yeah, man, you're apparently rude.
Oh, well, we're gonna be using in-game volume, though, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So if she's too low, I'd have to fix her right now.
I don't think she's ever fixable.
I don't think.
Are we all ready?
I think so.
I wanted to be the short girl, but she didn't have any cool outfits, really.
Alright, so we have player collision is on.
Proximity voice is on.
Batteries are on.
And medkits are on.
And perks are on.
I don't know what the perks are, but they're also on.
I don't have any because I've never played the game.
Oh, that's true.
So we're going straight in with, like, everything you need.
Everything possible.
So...
I've never played this game.
Not really sure what we're capable of, but...
It's gonna be great.
We're gonna do great.
There's an objective, and also make sure you have voice enabled.
I'm gonna mute Discord now.
Yeah, me too.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, I believe in us.
Do you guys believe?
Yeah.
Wait, let me see.
Let me see.
Can we, like, turn people up?
Maybe we can turn people up in-game, right?
I'm just turning down the music and the sound effects.
I'm turning up the game.
Oh, wait.
I forgot you could do that.
Right.
Okay, music, sound effects, and then...
I'll turn up the game more.
Alright.
Should be good.
Uh...
Okay.
Is this better?
Alright, guys.
Can you guys hear?
Can you guys hear me?
Okay,
I'll turn the music just a little bit down.
Because I don't want to hear the wedding...
The wedding thing for, like, the hundredth time.
I can't.
Alright, guys.
I'm readying it up now.
We're gonna go on a vacation, children.
With your dads.
Alright.
One of our sons is, like, at our age.
He just works outdoors a lot.
Yeah, yeah, he just...
We've been telling you that you don't...
We've been telling you that you haven't aged past ten.
So we think you're still ten years old.
That's... yeah.
Like, don't worry.
It's your tenth birthday again.
Yay!
Waiting for presents from Santa.
You wanna sit on Santa's lap?
Snuffy?
That was his other costume.
It was a Santa outfit, actually.
Wait, really?
He can be Santa.
Oh my god, no, you're right.
No, she's Benjamin Button.
She's Benjamin Button-ing it right now.
Benjamin Button was based off of our son.
It's the real story.
I need you to ready up.
Oh, sorry.
I'm ready.
I turned down my sound effects and brought up the game volume.
Let me know it's better, sound guy.
But we're going straight in.
What's this door?
Okay.
Oh, Azazel.
I know that from Supernatural.
Supernatural.
Wasn't he hot in Supernatural?
I can't remember.
That part.
That's how I know all the demons from Supernatural.
I know all the demons just because of Supernatural.
They were all hot.
Hello?
Wait, how do I turn- Oh, there you go.
Hello, guys.
Just so you guys know, our flashlight has batteries.
Just so you guys know.
I think so, right?
It's alright.
If our flashlight dies, it dies.
That's UV.
The UV requires batteries.
So like our- The right click.
You know when we burn the monsters out, burn the ghost, then we go Wait, Snuffy's not alive yet.
Snuffy is trapped in the- Is it because you're scared?
Don't worry.
Don't worry, son.
It's all you stick with.
No daddy, you'll be fine.
Look,
it's our vacation!
It's my vacation!
When there's a demon that comes at you- By the way, that's limited battery.
But-
We need to find batteries for it.
But like, it's used to chase away the monsters.
So when we go to this house, there's gonna be an objective.
I don't know if it starts the objective when we're- When we find something.
I feel like this is like different from the previous ones too.
I don't know about you guys, but my character is fucking incapable of jumping.
She's like so heavy or something.
It's my rat!
Don't worry, chat.
I'll be here to pick you.
I'll be here to catch you.
Don't worry, son.
I'll catch you.
I got a medkit.
There's a crow on this basin.
Or fountain, even.
I think he's an evil crow.
He has blue eyes.
Glowing?
Yeah.
Wait, I think that's- Oh wait, he's looking at us!
When it turned down my- When it turned down my sound effects.
What's wrong?
I just got a pumpkin.
What's wrong, dad?
Oh.
Oh, we have to destroy pumpkins.
Collect 60- Okay, we are not collecting 60 pumpkins.
Are they fucking satanic pumpkins or something?
I have no idea.
Oh!
Oh, look, a skull.
Oh, there's a dead person!
Get out!
I wanna see!
Let's take a picture!
That's our family photo!
Guys, let's take a family photo with- Oh, wait, where's his head?
Is this a headless horseman?
Wait, he's a priest.
Guys, alright, children.
Guys, it's time for a family photo, everybody.
Next to the dead body.
Yeah, yeah.
Sorry, say cheese, everybody!
Cheese!
Yeah, cheese!
I have no idea.
Up close.
Yay!
What a great start to our family vacation!
Wait, so is my light gonna, like, die?
No, no, no.
Oh, there's another dead- Oh, wait, there's a woman.
There's a woman here.
That's my wife.
Don't disrespect- Oh, nevermind, that's a child.
Excuse me?
I guess you're one of the bridesmaids.
You have to differentiate me!
I got a battery.
Is your rat useful?
Is he like a pig?
No, I think he just follows you.
I wish you got the pig.
Literally all he's doing is because a fucking player collision is on him, I keep getting stuck on him.
He's gonna rat you out.
Yeah, I wonder what happens, like, if you had the pig and you just have a fucking giant-ass pig following you around while you're getting chased.
Where do we go?
It was over this way before you ran off over the Oh, okay.
We just walked away to look at dead bodies.
I mean, we had to get our family photo.
The family photo was important, guys.
Oh, that's your wife!
There she is!
That's your dead wife.
That's my dead wife.
She's holding a camera.
That's your favorite thing.
In the bedroom.
Don't turn your black lights on around me, guys.
I'm a freak.
Is that another lady?
That's your grandma.
Oh, is that the chef?
It looks like a chef out there.
Oh, it does, yeah.
Jacob, the doorways.
Doorways are one people wide.
What?
Maybe I shouldn't put a collision on.
Oh.
Yeah, the door's locked.
Maybe there has to be a secret entrance somewhere.
The first struggle.
Finding the fucking door.
I've never played these games, so I'm relying on you guys.
Oh, there's a lab!
I've only played one or two.
Look, it's the Liza P protagonist.
Oh, hey!
He has a nice suit.
We both played Devoured, but apparently this map is different from the other Devour.
Oh, I think we parkour here, right?
Maybe up the tree?
Maybe.
Alright, guys, watch this.
Watch this, children.
This is how you do it.
Learn from us.
I don't really play these either, so it's gonna be great.
I think I'm stuck.
Wait, are you stuck?
Are you?
My dad's stuck.
We've been waiting in there for hours.
I can't even get...
Oh, we did it!
Okay, I need to turn my sense up.
My sensitivity is way too low.
I know, I had to turn mine up too.
Okay.
I wonder how long it's gonna take for one of us to get yoinked.
And then it takes like 10 years for anybody else to notice.
There's a window right there!
There's a door!
How do we get in?
Wait, there's another gate here.
Maybe we have to go to the gate over there.
Oh, there it is!
There's the other door.
Guys, we found it!
We found the door!
Get over here, children!
Get over here.
Alright, Snuffy.
Okay, Snuffy, do you wanna be a...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Snuffy, do you wanna be a brave boy today?
Do you wanna be a man today?
No!
Oh, it's my rat.
My rat's a little special.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh my god, whose birthday is it?
Wait, there's a note.
Michael's dead.
I can't believe it.
He's dead.
What the fuck?
What is your character's...
Stop that.
How did you do that?
I got his voice right.
Press Q.
Press the numbers.
The numbers.
Okay, man.
Come on!
What the fuck?
I maybe kinda spent like a dollar on the macaroon.
Oh my god, it's Fortnite!
It's Fortnite!
Bro, before you die, you got Macarena into it.
Oh my god, your rat is dancing too!
He's looking at me.
I got an item.
Oh, you can only pick one item.
You can only pick one.
I have a medkit.
I don't know.
This guy drew a heart in blood.
I can have a medkit.
Or a booze bomb.
Can you bring yourself up a little bit in game?
You're a little quiet for me.
Compared to everybody.
Maybe a little bit more.
I don't know.
How do I do it in game?
Oh, I think it's a lot better.
Maybe because I have to be close to you.
Oh, there's another dead person.
Oh, there's a tunnel!
How did we miss the tunnel?
I saw the tunnel.
Are we guys ready?
I'm the British SpongeBob.
I'm ready.
Okay,
let's see.
I can fix this.
I've seen the ritual to summon a Zazel.
I think I can do it.
I'll make him open a portal to the realm of the dead.
Then I'll find Michael there and we can be together again.
Oh, sorry.
I just made the sacrifices.
Alright.
Well, I guess we...
I love how that's like a Professor Layton English voice.
It's very good.
This reminds me of a puzzle.
A puzzle, Professor?
Professor?
How many demons put away the books?
It's just like what if he went to a haunted house.
Whoa!
Whoa, where did she go?
She's in the...
You're in the mirror.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's freaky.
Okay, that...
That sat in the fucking tendrils.
Don't stand on the tendril that's gonna grab you.
What are we supposed to do over here?
Oh my god, it's so spooky.
Whoa, the ambience here.
Wait, there's people inside that door.
Yeah, I hear them crying.
Wait, you think it's a ghost?
Maybe, maybe we should go... Wait, I hear them on the other side.
This is like Stranger Things.
We're in the other world.
We're in the other worlds.
We gotta get the flickering lights to communicate with our children.
Oh, there's another note here.
Let's see.
That's a bunch of names.
John, Jasmine, Hakeem, Nicholas, Eric, Tyra, Madison, Ashley, Christopher, Ellie...
The upside down.
Wait, there's another mirror here.
Oh, hey, Peekaboo!
We're back!
Wait, what did you see?
You opened the door?
Why did you open the door?
You're not supposed to touch anything!
That's the number one rule!
Don't touch anything!
What?
But I've been picking up all the cake.
What did you do?
That's literally Horror Movie 101!
Don't touch random things!
Why would we be here if we're not meant to touch stuff?
We're meant to touch everything.
Okay,
we'll go with...
Alright, your turn.
Alright, we're good.
Bye, Snuffy!
By the way, we left Snuffy, by the way.
She's literally walking around talking to herself right now.
Oh, there you are!
Alright.
Alright, it's time to go in.
Oh, there she is!
Did I get her?
I think so.
No, I think we're supposed to interact.
Alright, Snuffy, time for another big boy moment.
Don't you wanna be a man, Snuffy?
Guys...
Oh, yeah, I don't think she appreciated it.
Oh my god, you did it!
Now you're a real man.
Now you'll have a girlfriend, son.
Now you won't be a disappointment no more.
That's true.
I'm in the other world.
Hey, guys, get over here in the other world!
Oh my god, there are painters!
Oh, there's a key!
I got a key!
I grabbed a balcony key.
Oh my god, that's a painting of a child.
A child walking into a tree doorway magical entrance.
That legitimately looks like the park you have to clean in Power Wash Sim.
Oh, yeah, that's true!
It is!
Maybe they got a screenshot of that and then just, you know, in Photoshop, you can just do Paintify.
I don't understand why every VTuber knows which park it is.
I literally just did the Power Wash Sim today for a Shrek DLC.
It just came out.
Was it good?
Oh, there's feathers too?
What is this game?
Oh, I was gonna do that next week.
Was it good?
Yeah, but you need a... Okay, it was... The Shrek Swamp is literally the last level.
So you have to go through so much just to get the swamp.
I literally cleaned for four hours.
And, like, banned one person.
I banned a person after it.
Oh, I know!
You banned a Shrek-related streamer!
Yeah, was the Shrek level the only one?
What did you have to do?
No, there's three levels.
I think there's... I don't know if there's more than three.
But the first level is Lord Farquaad's place.
The second level is literally the Shrek honeymoon house.
And then the third one is the swamp.
How did you know about... Oh, I got the key.
How did you...
How did you know about the grass story?
How did you know?
How did you know about grass?
Oh, because grass came to my chat and was just like...
He knows what he did.
Oh, it's just a mention.
Let's go see what they're doing.
He's creepy.
Let's not look at him anymore.
Who's creepy?
Oh, he's like waddling in there.
Oh, no, thank you.
Who is?
Look at the... There's a head.
There is?
I think we have to burn it with the...
Wait, is he biting my fucking ankles?
What am I hearing dying?
What the fuck is that noise?
Oh, he's over there.
Oh, he is.
Wait, we gotta follow the head.
Follow the head.
Look, he's crying.
You're torturing him.
What if we double-team him?
Yeah, what if we double-team him?
I get him from behind.
Yeah.
Where is he trying to go?
Is he trying to go back to his home?
There's a lady!
Oh, God.
I don't know if you can burn her.
Wait, you can?
Maybe when she's aggravated, right?
Maybe.
Oh, you cannot.
I don't think you're supposed to touch her.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to the...
The other world.
I'm with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, well, we have to go back so we can get to the head.
Right?
What do we do with the cake and stuff?
Maybe it's like health.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
Alright, is it fine?
Is it safe, Stealthy?
Guys, I hear growling inside the mirror.
Okay, the ghost is currently in the room banging her head against the wall.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Yeah.
That should be fine.
Yeah, let's just go follow the head now.
Let's just go, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where did the head go?
Oh, there she is!
There's the head!
Alright.
Okay, follow her.
Where are you gonna go?
Where is he going?
Wait, he's going backwards.
Are we supposed to kill it?
There's a bunch of names on this.
Wait, did we kill this?
Where are you killing?
Oh, I killed it!
Oh!
Oh, I'm okay.
Oh, oh, yeah, she's dead.
Yeah, she's dead.
Did you touch her?
You're not supposed to touch her!
Hold on, I left my medkit in there.
Did you guys touch the spaghetti sauce?
No, no, she touched a lady.
She touched a woman.
No, I touched the tentacles again.
You guys stopped doing that.
The therapist told you guys to stop touching those tentacles.
I thought I killed them!
Wait, what do we do?
I can't interact with the head guy.
He didn't seem to care that I was lighting him up.
No, he didn't really do anything.
Yeah, should we just follow the head?
We just follow it?
There's like a door that opened.
Oh, wait, this door is open too.
Some of these doors weren't open before.
That's true.
I wonder if we open them in the shadow, if it opens...
Oh, are we supposed to put the cake...
No, right?
Yeah, that was meant, I think.
Put the cake back together.
All the plates, yeah.
That will stop the demons.
What, then she knows it's like happy birthday!
Wait, I'm gonna go find a piece of cake and I'll come back to put it together.
Wait, no, I have a piece of cake.
I can't put it back down.
It's too late, she's gone.
Let's let them do their thing.
You need the kitchen key, apparently.
Oh, okay, we just gotta find the kitchen key.
There was a door upstairs that opened that I don't think was open before, but I'm a little bitch baby, so I don't wanna go look.
Don't worry, there's a closet key here.
Oh, there's another door here!
Oh, we opened... oh, wait, no, this is the...
Alright, we opened that...
Oh, that's the front door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice!
What's up here in this one?
Is there a time limit on these?
No, no, no, I think we just... I think it's the other world.
What if we bring the cake to the other world?
Oh, you got the closet key!
Wait, I know where the closet key is.
Come follow me, Mint.
Wait, where's Mint?
Oh, we found the creepy children's bedroom.
Oh, the children... Okay, wait, I wanna see the children first.
Or the kids.
I don't remember seeing a second dead kid, so...
Okay.
Are we gonna get haunted by another one?
There's so many books on the floor.
Oh, what's this?
Seven days to go.
Can't wait to see you walk down that aisle.
Back at six, I'll cook.
Okay, there's an upstairs bedroom.
What's this?
You're upstairs?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, we're coming back down.
We should come back downstairs.
She has the keys.
Sure.
We'll come back downstairs.
There's a closet below.
Wait, I'll grab the children.
Kids!
Kids, we got the keys, kids!
Dude, check this out!
Look at this!
Here it is.
A wag over here?
Oh no.
A wag over here.
Alright, kids.
We gotta go get... We gotta go to the closet and the kitchen.
Min has the closet key and the kitchen key.
Maybe I should not put player collision on.
Maybe...
You decided this.
It's the real devour experience.
It's true, true, it is.
We're pushing each other out of the door.
One person blocks the door for everybody else.
Where is... It was like here.
This is the... Is this... No.
There was a closet door somewhere.
Oh, what is this though?
Oh, this is where the wedding happened.
Oh, is this the wedding?
Whoa, okay.
This looks really fucking scary.
Hey, this... That looks like a scary...
That's his house.
See, that's his whole house.
Oh, there's the dead husband.
Where... Oh, there he is!
I hope he had a great time.
Where did...
Oh, it's a... It's a development room for photographs.
Is there anything in here?
Oh, there's more... Alright, alright, Stuffy.
What does it say?
Azazel made me do it.
Azazel made me...
That's what it says.
Oh, hey, I have a shovel.
Whoa, that's Raw's hat.
Can you hit the ghost with that?
I think so, maybe.
Why else would I have a shovel?
Oh, maybe I get the shovel and then, like, bury the bodies after getting their heads back there.
Oh, this is how we're gonna find out which head goes on which head!
Guys, this is how we're gonna find out.
But, like, I don't...
I don't remember which head... What was the head that we saw?
Are we supposed to chase...
He had, like, a little bacon and I couldn't tell at all.
Yeah, like, he got... He was all, like, decomposed and everything.
How the fuck...
How the fuck are we supposed to figure out?
They were all decomposed.
The bride has, like, a flower crown, I guess.
I guess, like...
I don't know, maybe the bride made it.
Do you think they'll have the...
Maybe, like, maybe it's this guy.
Which one?
That guy.
Cause I think, like, the other one...
I think they maybe have glasses on.
Maybe we're gonna supposed to chase the head.
We're supposed to chase the head to the bodies.
I don't think so.
Then why the fuck... Why would I have a shovel?
Why would there be photos of heads?
And then running heads?
I think you should...
Can you, like, put the soil back in?
No.
I think we're supposed to...
I'm pretty sure we're supposed to...
And then...
And then bury it.
It's like a delivery service.
Oh my god.
That's you.
What if that's...
That's you before you died.
That's literally me.
That's literally you.
Where did your head go?
We took you back to where you died.
Bury me, Doki.
The lore!
You're happier as a phantom.
What's over there?
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's downstairs.
Wait, we have to...
Oh, wait, wait.
Min has the kitchen key.
Wait, wait, wait.
Since we opened this area, maybe the ghost will run here.
Maybe the ghost head will run here now.
Where the fuck are we?
How many dead bodies?
Oh, there's a gardener.
No, it's a gardener.
That's the pig thing.
Bro, she fucked...
That guy got beheaded.
Do you think he wants to get beheaded?
Maybe.
Wait, there's a crypt here.
There's a bigger grave.
I think there's a grave here, too.
Oh, this is where they summoned Azazel.
Wait, this is where we were!
We were here!
Oh!
Oh, hey, I found her.
So we found the loop-de-loop.
We found the loop-de-loop.
Also, chat, is the volume better now?
Is my sound better?
Can you hear everybody?
Or is people too loud?
Wait, we can open the kitchen key.
Minh has the kitchen.
It is right here.
Right here, yeah, yeah.
Oh, hey, there's a pig!
There's your pet pig!
There you go.
There's more cake.
Wait, let's get to the other world.
Wait, there's the other world.
Is this safe?
Oh, there's a head in here.
He can't get out.
Oh, I told you!
We gotta lead him!
Or let him out.
Let him out!
No, we gotta let him out!
I'm leading him out!
I can't hit him with the shovel!
Go!
Go to your head!
Wait, I think we're supposed to herd them to the bodies.
Oh, we're herding them!
We're herding the pets!
Oh shit, am I...
Who's getting hit by the...
Alright,
herd the heads!
Herd the heads to the bodies!
That's almost like maybe feeding cake.
Take him to outside.
We got the outside door.
We should take him to the outside like a good dog.
Good dog, good dog.
Wait, why do we have two heads now?
Oh god.
Because we found two heads!
Yeah, there's like a second head.
Wait, try the cake?
Who has a cake?
Wait, who has...
Oh my god, wait!
They're meeting!
The dogs are meeting!
Alright, are you guys having a good time?
Are you two...
Are you guys becoming friends?
Oh look, they're playing with each other!
We're the worst dog walkers ever!
Wait, what's that?
What's that?
Oh, I'm going to the other world!
I think we're in trouble.
As long as we're here, we'll be fine, right?
Wait, I'm gonna try to feed...
I don't know.
Let's just hide in the kitchen.
Yeah, let's just...
No, let's bring...
Somebody's...
Why'd you get rid of your weapon?
It doesn't work!
I'm trying to...
Somebody said we should feed the heads cake!
Feed them cake?
Yeah, they said to feed them cake!
Are you guys okay?
No!
What happened?
Wait, she's in the other world!
She's here, we go back to there!
Alright, do you want some cake?
How did you get over there?
Hello?
Oh my god, am I still alive?
Yeah, you are.
I'm not alive on the other side.
Hello?
What?
Oh, there you are!
We're on the... Oh, there you are!
How are you alive?
She snapped your spine!
She got better.
Look, I'm good.
That was the scariest thing I've ever experienced in my entire life.
She snapped your fucking spine and you disintegrated.
Do you want the cake, little guy?
You want it?
Wait, wait, he's walking away!
Drop the cake!
Drop Gigi, press G!
He was walking over!
G, G, G!
Press G, press G!
G, G, G, baby!
Watch, watch!
Oh my god, you got this!
You got this, boy!
Little dog!
Go, go!
Come on!
Oh, good boy!
She disappeared!
You have the head.
Oh, I have the head?
Is the head on me?
Where's the head?
I have...
I have them in my inventory.
Gigi, the witch is in the real world now.
She went through the mirror and killed Snuffy, and now she's out there.
And Snuffy is, for some reason, still alive.
Snuffy, can you go back through the mirror?
Do you die again?
I mean...
No, I revived her.
Oh, okay, okay.
Alright, okay, so...
Yeah, you fucking disintegrated on my screen.
Okay, so there's bodies...
Okay, so, all we have to do is that we just have to...
We have to go outside.
We have to get the...
There's bodies outside, so we piece those heads to that body.
Do we have to go back to the real world then?
Yeah, I think so.
It doesn't matter whose body it is.
Okay, so we go back to the real world and find the bodies?
Yeah, there's a grave over there.
Wait, does anyone...
We need to find a cake, then.
We have to go to the other world.
Everyone should grab a head.
Yeah, but we need to find more cake.
We need to feed them cake first.
I swear there was so much cake before.
I think it's on the other world.
It's in the other world.
Oh, okay, okay.
We might need to go back to the normal world for cake.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, who has the shovel?
The shovel's gone.
It's in the normal world.
Oh, I left it in the normal world.
The shovel is right here.
Okay, okay, I'll grab the shovel.
I'll grab it just in case.
Alright, we just gotta find cake.
Do you want to go and try and attach that head?
Yeah, let's see if it works.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I have the shovel with me.
I'm scared of the lady, though.
Don't worry.
She's right there.
Wait, she's on your right.
She's out inside.
No, no, she's inside.
We're outside now.
Okay.
Does it work?
Oh, the head must be cleansed before playing.
What the hell does that mean?
What the fuck does that mean?
Maybe back to the creepy ritual room?
Maybe.
Maybe, yeah, yeah, yeah.
In the coffin or whatever.
Oh, yeah, yeah, someone said clean it with alcohol in the altar.
We need to find alcohol.
What?
Oh, that's all the booze.
This way, then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
How much is there?
I didn't realize those were like story relevant items.
I like how we just pour some booze on it to fix it.
Okay.
Oh, here's some.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Wow.
If it can clean wounds, it can clean heads.
Okay.
That's what rubbing alcohol taught me.
Oh, my God.
Clean it.
Give it a little bath.
Give the little boy a bath.
It's our little pet.
Oh, my God.
There's a head.
Oh, she's a lady.
Oh, she's beautiful.
Wait, can you drop the head so we can look at it?
Oh.
That looks like a maid.
Do you think that's a maid?
I think that's you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do I grab it?
E.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Let's...
Here you go.
There you go.
Sin.
The backyard.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no.
Lime has it.
We need to go find her now.
We can look at the pictures again.
There weren't that many pictures, though.
There weren't that many pictures.
What if we... What if we find whoever... They don't care whose head they get.
Like, whatever.
Yeah, I know.
As long as they're like, you know...
Oh, oh.
Oh, she is...
Back in the tiny cavern.
Back in the tiny cavern that would play your collision.
Let's go this way.
I don't think we can.
We don't have stamina to jump.
Oh.
Oh, we can't go out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a one-way entrance.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Well, she can only kill one person.
Did she leave?
Okay, guys.
Come on.
Alright.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't have anything.
I'm gonna grab... Yeah, grab the cake.
Grab the cake.
There's another piece of cake here.
Okay.
I'm gonna take the shovel, because I'm...
There's a bathroom key.
Lime had it, right?
This one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One of the heads might be stuck in the bathroom.
There we go.
I should find where to put this one, though, before I get killed.
There is a cake in here.
Yeah, let's figure out the...
Oh, maybe it's in the ghost world?
Let's go outside.
Alright, where's...
Did she come out here?
I don't know, but...
Let's go...
Wait.
The head does not belong here.
Is it her?
How do we get to the maid area?
Remember the maid?
It was like, in the back of the house.
I think it's the maid.
It has to be.
Try putting it on this...
Lime did.
Oh my God, so we actually have to guess?
No, it's in the photos, remember?
The photos that we saw there.
Yeah, but there weren't that many photos.
The audio cut off.
Is she there?
I think the audio...
Are you guys okay?
Oh, there she is.
You guys okay?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Um...
Oh.
What's she doing?
She's crawling on her knees.
Getting...
Oh.
Hey there.
Are you okay, ma'am?
A week of hard work right there.
When the week is fun.
Okay, I got it.
This way.
What?
We need the shovel.
The corpse is freaking out.
It's wanting attention.
Oh my God.
Where is it?
Is she okay?
I knew it.
See, I told you.
I told you.
I told you that's the maid.
I could see the maid.
Alright, get in there.
Bury you alive.
So you can be returned your soul to the body.
Return your soul to the body.
Go back to where you belong.
Midden Hell.
Oh, she's angry.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, why is she on me?
It's the crows!
The crows are...
Hello?
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Where did everybody go?
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared, son.
Where's Lyman?
Son, I'm so scared.
Oh my God.
Okay, let's go to the crypt.
Let's go to the crypt.
Okay, okay, okay.
Follow dad.
Don't worry.
Let's go to the crypt.
Okay, here, here.
Oh my God.
I have alcohol, so I'm just gonna pre-put the alcohol in the thing.
I'm gonna need them myself.
I still have cake.
I should've grabbed one of my alcohols.
Yeah, I'm just pre-putting it now.
What happened to Lyman?
Did they just vanish?
I think they ran inside.
Okay.
So, we have to go back in.
Are you guys alive?
Hello?
Lyman?
Look out, the crows.
What's that light?
That's them, that's them.
I think that's them.
In front of the house.
She ran inside.
Oh.
Oh God.
We gotta go to the other world.
Stuffy, Stuffy, go to the other world.
Stuffy, come over here.
Son!
Get over here.
Grab the cake.
Feed him, feed him.
Press G, press G.
Come on, little boy.
Come on.
Come on, you know you want that cake.
Who wants that little cake?
You guys can't all be hungry.
I think they're all hungry.
Somebody's crying, somebody's crying.
Is she coming?
Oh.
Oh, we gotta grab him.
We didn't grab him!
We were supposed to grab him when he was eating!
He took the cake!
He just took the fucking cake!
We were supposed to grab him while he was eating!
I got another cake.
Don't worry, I got another cake.
Okay, okay.
Right here, right here.
Alright, little guy.
Alright, come eat the cake.
Come eat the cake, little guy.
You know you want to.
You know...
Alright, I got one of the heads.
Okay, we should put all the heads...
We should put all the heads near the altar, because every time you put the body into a head, she gets angrier.
Yeah, she gets angrier.
Okay, there was another one.
Alright, let's like...
Let's head back downstairs.
I'm heading back downstairs.
Oh my god, we got the cake.
Okay, she gets angry, so I'm scared of her getting angry.
There we go.
Oh, what?!
You run away if I drop you, you little fucker!
We need another cake.
Do you have another cake?
I didn't realize...
No, don't drop the...
I didn't realize he runs away!
Maybe we should cleanse them?
Yeah, cleanse them and then drop them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They can't run after we cleanse them.
Can we run out of cake?
I don't think so.
There's no way.
There must be enough cake.
Guys, guys, we found... we figured out a strat.
We have to just...
Oh, what?
But she sounds like she's calm now.
Did you guys chill her out?
I used the UV light on her.
Oh, okay.
So, like, we clean a bunch of heads and then drop... put it in the altar after we clean them.
So then, like, you know how when we put the heads in the body, they get angrier?
So all we have to do is just, like, have a pile of clean heads at the altar.
Okay.
I have a head currently.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come with me.
I cleansed... I have alcohol already in the altar.
Okay, okay.
Alright, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here.
Alright.
I'll grab this one, too, just cause...
Okay.
So we can head downstairs.
Alright, alright, alright.
Downstairs.
I thought the cake would make them... I dropped a head in the tomb, by the way.
Because I didn't realize he would run after I dropped him, but he...
I think she only gets aggroed...
I think she only gets aggroed once we bury the body.
So we can probably attach the heads and then go around and bury the body.
Oh, that's true!
That's true!
Yeah, we can do that.
I'll fill it up again, too.
Oh.
Uh, I think a little guy just escaped.
There's a head walking around.
Yeah, no, that was me.
I didn't realize that he starts moving.
I didn't realize he starts moving.
After I dropped him, I thought I could just put him there.
Wait, let's grab him.
Where is he?
I don't have a cake, though.
Oh, we need more cake.
Yeah, yeah, we need more cake.
No!
Send me, send me, send me.
Wash his head, wash his head.
Oh, that's the cook!
This is the cook!
Yeah, yeah, we can attach.
I'm just thinking when we attach them, do you think they'll run away because they're, like, vibrating?
Oh, they're chained down.
I got John Alpha Male over here.
John Alpha Male?
What does he look like?
Wait, is that the groom?
Yeah, yeah, that could be the groom.
Ooh, she's gonna get excited.
You're gonna be... let's make them kiss.
Let's make a circle of heads.
I like how girls can make heads.
Alright, I'll hold my head, you hold your head, and maybe they can kiss.
Make them kiss.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are they kissing?
We're playing Barbie dolls.
Yeah, we're playing Barbie dolls with the head.
Oh, this one head over here is, like, gagging.
Yeah, he's still... he's waiting for...
He's pouting.
He's, like, in the corner.
We're chasing him back into the...
No, stop!
Go back!
Nobody loves you!
That's rude.
Chase him back!
Oh, he got out.
He got out.
Aw, man.
One jump.
Uh-oh.
Okay, I'm back here, I guess.
Wait, is she in this world or the other?
I can't tell.
I'd never know.
I'm just scared forever.
I think she's...
Is it really loud?
I think she's in the... I think she's in the inside world.
I think she's in the real world.
Where's Limu?
Did she die?
Oh, my God!
That's so loud!
I'm sorry!
Oh, my God!
I'm so sorry!
Let me turn this...
Holy shit!
Let me turn this out of it.
Oh, no.
Please.
Please!
Anybody help!
She's in the other world!
In the other world?
Yeah, she got me from behind.
She got me...
She got me from in the mirror.
That's so sad for you.
Bye.
We're gonna run out of med kits.
I'm scared.
Oh, my God.
I got the head.
I was literally against the mirror and then she fucking jumped out from the mirror.
I think it might be in the other world.
Yeah, I know.
I was right there.
You watched it happen.
Okay, I'm gonna put the head on her.
I got one of them.
I got her.
Wow, she sounds a little...
I think...
What does she sound...
I mean, at least she's having a good time.
You didn't complain.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
You get closer to the body.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As long as we bury them.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
They're fine like that.
Probably.
We got five more cake.
I'm gonna get more cake slices.
Yeah, I'm gonna get alcohol then when you get cake slice.
I got alcohol.
There's more cake slices at the balcony.
So much cake outside.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, there's a...
Wait, wait.
We have a head, right?
Wait, do you guys...
Oh, you got one?
I got the groom.
Yeah, I was the groom.
I wanna see him.
Wait, I wanna see him.
Is he here?
Oh, there he is.
Look at him.
He doesn't say anything.
Oh, he does.
He's just very quiet.
Yeah, he's just like...
He's whimpering a little bit.
Pussy.
Whimper a little bit.
Oh, I found more cake.
Yeah, I have alcohol.
Wait, we need that so we can get that guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta go to the other world.
There's one on the table here.
We gotta go to the...
There's three slices in here, actually.
I have a shovel in the other world.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a shovel right here, too.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll just wait.
Yeah, yeah.
We don't wanna aggro her.
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
We should go to the other world.
And feed some...
Where's the one...
Where's the head that's in here?
Well, we have to go to the other world.
It's over here, right?
Yeah, this is the real world.
He was here.
No, he was in the real world.
Wait, he was?
How is he in the real world?
How did you get here?
Remember?
We were just...
Some of them were in the real world.
Oh, okay.
Someone feed him.
I don't have it.
I think we accidentally brought him here.
And then when you dropped him down...
Oh, yeah.
I brought him here.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Doki.
I was the one that dropped him.
That's my child.
Okay,
we have alcohol.
Oh, yeah.
I have extra too.
My early onset dementia.
Look, I'm old right now.
I'm playing an old guy.
I'm just role-playing.
I'm just role-playing as the old man.
Look at him squirm.
He's so cute.
Wait, what does she do?
Look, you can see your...
Oh, I wonder if it was a bat.
Or a crow.
Yeah, I burned that crow.
Okay, I'm refilling the...
I have the lady in the backyard.
I'm gonna go put her on.
Alright, I'm gonna put more alcohol in here.
Okay.
Okay, I don't have a med kit though.
Hi, Snuffy.
What happened to you, son?
He's like really groaning.
Oh, shit, she's pissed.
Oh, shit, is she in the other world?
I can't tell.
I can't tell, I'm just gonna follow you.
I don't know where she is.
Oh, it's her!
It's the flower girl!
Yeah, yeah, I got her.
Yay!
Alright, we gotta find a med kit for her.
Yeah.
I have another cake.
I have cake.
Is that alcohol?
If she comes up to us, you can calm her down with UV.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll just be like...
Like, blue is a very common color.
She's basically Bridezilla.
She's upstairs?
Alright.
Women, am I right?
Oh, women, am I right, son?
Oh, look!
She's no longer Bridezilla.
Oh, there she is.
She's like, still around, but she's not pissed.
Guys, we need to get her a med kit.
Guys!
There you go, okay.
We have two cakes for...
Oh shit, there's a crow.
We have two cakes for a head, so we gotta go to the other world.
Yeah, let's go to the other world.
There's one, the one that I was like, I tripped and fell is upstairs.
You tripped and fell?
Wait, there's a mirror here, there's a mirror here.
She's in the ghost world, yeah.
The head is in the ghost world, so it should be okay.
Watch out for the...
Yeah, I have extra cake as well.
I figured, I think the ghosts like, regenerate the tentacle things.
Or the heads.
They like, feed them.
I'm right here behind you, where is he?
Oh, it's in this one.
And he was in that one.
Oh, he's here, he's here.
Alright.
Go eat your cake.
Come on, boy.
Come on.
Yes, you want the cake?
Oh, you do?
Okay, fine!
Fine, where is he?
Did he run?
There we go.
Alright, let's do this.
There you go.
That's what happens when you complain.
I'll turn the car around.
You think I won't?
I will turn the car around.
Does anybody have a...
Upstairs bathroom?
Yeah, someone did.
I think that was Min.
Yeah, Min had it.
Yeah, alright.
I can hear her.
Yeah, how do we get to the...
We gotta go to the other side.
Min, do you have the upstairs bathroom key?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure we got it.
It's up here.
Right side, right side.
No, no, no, right side.
Right here.
The door over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Left, left, right here.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, you did.
Oh, what?
I remember you had an upstairs something.
I have a...
I have a head.
I have the closet key.
Oh, okay.
I have cake, if we have a...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do we have another head?
I have cake also.
I have not seen one.
How many have we had so far?
Uh...
I'm holding one right now, so...
I'm gonna go to...
I wanna go to the other world to clean this one, though.
No head?
Where did our head go?
Alright.
I feel like we should get two...
One more, at least.
Do you know...
Wait, you know where the closet was, right?
Did you?
Yeah, it was at the bottom.
The closet was at the bottom.
The closet's down here.
It's down here.
Or did I?
It's open on this side, but it might not be open on the other side.
Oh yeah, the other world.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh wait, I think I did.
Nevermind.
Oh, that's a bad word.
Not if you're Australian!
Oh, you two streamers demonetized.
I'm gonna go wash the head.
Oh, I hear her bashing her head.
Guys, for one day, I shall be Australian.
It's okay, guys.
I can say that technically I'm in Australia right now.
Whose head is this?
Oh, it's the girl with red hair.
Okay.
I wonder whose head she belongs to.
Wait.
Guys, guys, guys!
Guys, are you in the other world?
No.
Guys, come over here.
The crows take the heads!
The crows take the heads if we don't bury them.
Oh my god, no way!
Oh my god.
What?
The crows take it.
The crows take the head if you don't bury them.
Oh, well that makes sense.
Wait, do you think there would be crows taking the head at the altar then?
Maybe we should just...
Just like stockpile heads at the altar.
It's really easy to calm her down, so we just calm her down.
Yeah, let's calm her down.
Wait, that just lifted up.
Yeah, she did that earlier.
Oh, really?
Okay, let's calm her then.
Where is she?
Oh no.
Here she is.
Calm down, girl.
Calm down.
The wedding will be okay.
Let's just bury the heads and calm her down.
The wedding will be okay, lady.
Don't worry.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
So this isn't concerning you, leave.
Okay, let's put the head.
Wait, does that...
Okay, the crow hasn't taken that head yet.
I have two bodies here.
I'm gonna go bury them.
I'm gonna grab the shovel on the other side.
What was that?
Oh, who was that?
Wait.
Oh, you blind buried them.
Oh, you buried them.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we have two more.
Yeah, she seems not happy.
Alright, are you guys ready to bury more?
Alright, I'm gonna...
Wait, did she say I'll get you?
Alright, let's make her angrier.
Let's make her angrier.
Let's make her ang...
Oh.
Wait, what?
Okay, so we made her angrier.
Alright, let's just stockpile heads then.
We'll stockpile heads.
Wait, where did Snuffy go?
I can heal her.
I think she's in the other world.
I think I pissed her off that time.
I think it's supposed to get harder as the game goes on.
Oh, no, it is, it is.
That's how devour works, yeah.
The more heads we're returning, the more power she unlocks for some reason because she pissed.
We have to go to the other world!
Okay, let's stockpile heads in the altar.
Let's stockpile heads...
Can you pick up this head?
And we'll put all the heads in the altar and then we'll start...
And then we'll...
There's no way the crows will head to the altar.
There's no way.
It's our safe place.
Yeah, the crows can't go in because there's God on our side.
I thought you loved Satan.
I love Satan.
You don't love God, you love Satan.
Wait, who took the other head that went...
Oh, you have it?
No, Lime has it.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, I think she went to the altar.
I think she went to stockpile it.
I see Snuffy, I'm gonna go heal her.
Alright, I'm gonna go to the crypt and...
Put more alchohol.
Are you okay?
You're just standing there.
I was just like...
Yeah, I was just slightly possessed by the tiredness demon.
Yeah, I was like, oh my God, that's a little freaky.
There's no way there's gonna be crows here.
A crow does kinda spawn in here for what it's worth.
Okay, we'll hide it.
We'll hide the head.
There's no way they'll find the head here.
Our little stockpile of heads.
Oh, I see Snuffy.
Oh, I think they...
I think...
Oh, she mad already.
There's no way she'll be on here, this side, right?
This is our safe spot.
I think she came in here before.
Wait, she did?
She came like halfway down the tunnel, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah, when she was chasing Mintonite, she came all the way in.
Oh, you're alive!
Hey guys, I'm back alive again.
How did you die?
She was like, I'm gonna get you guys again.
She's like, oh, you guys win.
Just kidding.
Yeah, she was classified, and then she went, haha, that's a joke.
And actually just murdered Snuffy.
Yeah, I think it only stuns her now.
It doesn't like actually...
Yeah, yeah, alright.
So now, we'll stockpile all the heads in this corner.
So we'll be fine.
Alright, we just need to find more heads.
I have not seen five heads.
There's no way.
Unless they're all trapped in the bathroom.
They're all just trapped in one bathroom.
Seriously?
Actually, no.
Does anybody have any cake?
Okay, you're not safe in the other world.
Oh, somebody said red eyes can't be stunned.
She will have red eyes.
Okay, okay.
Red eyes can't be stunned.
The lore, the...
Yeah, that's when you know she's extra Bridezilla.
Should we go into the other world?
Oh, I think that's her.
Is she... that's her outside?
I think that's her outside.
The red eyes black tribe.
Shine, shine, shine, shine, shine.
Oh, shine, shine, shine, shine.
We got you, we got you.
Where did that head come from?
Wow, they're all multiplying.
Does anybody have cake?
Oh, I thought you guys had cake.
I don't have cake.
Okay, I'm gonna go to the other world.
Okay, time to find cake.
I found alcohol.
You found some?
No, I found alcohol.
Did I just hear her?
Wait.
Oh, they got the... they got this head.
They got this head.
I'll take it to the altar.
Was that the head from the altar?
No, no.
This is not the one from the altar.
Oh, okay.
It better not be.
Wait, they can't come in here though, don't you?
We've zapped them from in here before.
But this is a different head, but they can definitely come in here.
Yeah, yeah.
No, but there's no way they can find it.
There's no way.
It's in our corner.
It's our safe space corner.
It's our safe space, yeah.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta find...
Wait, what the f... Oh my God, fuck off!
It's literally you.
And I know what I'm like.
Yeah, we all do.
It can only be one.
One is already too many.
Oh yeah, cake.
Nice.
I found cake too.
I found... There's three cakes here.
There's three cakes here.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Let's get the head.
Head time.
Get the head.
Where is it?
I'm heading to the other side.
Where's the... Where's the heads?
Oh, she's downstairs.
She's downstairs.
She's bashing her head again.
Look at her go.
Don't worry, ma'am.
We'll save your wedding.
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
If you don't want your wedding to be saved, that's...
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
She wants to kill us.
She wants...
She really wants to kill us.
What do we do?
What do...
Oh, where is she?
Is she... Is she here with us?
I can't tell.
We're good.
We're running.
I got another head.
Oh, nice, nice.
I got a...
I also got cake too for this head.
I'm gonna head over here.
Where's... Where's the other head?
I thought you guys said there wasn't a head here.
Oh, there's a head.
Come over here.
Come on, boy.
Which... Which cake... Which...
Okay, I'll put this cake in the... I'll put this cake in the altar.
Okay, we found... We have another head with us.
We have another head.
I'm putting this cake downstairs.
I can confirm a crow just showed up in here and stole one of the heads.
I killed it, but they will steal the heads in here.
No!
No, okay, but, like, you can't steal all the heads.
As long as we come back...
Wait, Sophie died.
Yeah, I got you.
Wait, no, no, wait.
Wait, Mint died.
Mint died.
It's okay.
As long as there's one of us guarding the heads, we should be fine.
You can't have all... All the crows can't be here.
I don't trust myself to maneuver.
I've... I've died enough.
I can make friends with the heads.
Sure.
Okay, put them in that corner.
Okay, how many more do we need total?
We need... I think, like, two more.
I don't remember.
There were so many bodies.
Maybe three more.
There's so many guys.
Okay, I'm gonna put this in here.
Oh, she's mad.
Oh.
Sophie, are you okay?
What happened?
Wait, I think she's trying to... I think she's fighting off... Is that the bride?
Is that the bride?
Oh, she's so angry!
No!
Oh my god.
We got her, we got her, we got her, we got her, we got her, we got her.
Okay, she's calm, it's calm.
We gotta grab that medkit.
Mint!
Mint, we're coming!
We don't have a medkit, I have a cake, though!
It's almost like a medkit!
Ow, stop!
Where's the medkit?
Where's the medkit, Mint?
Wait, there's a medkit in here!
It's right here, it's right here.
There's lots of cake and stuff in here, too.
There you go, I got you.
That's good.
Alright.
Someone in my chat said we'll have to stun her multiple times now to calm her down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have more cake as well.
Check the bodies for the bathroom key, bro.
How do we open this door?
Oh, she's right there.
What's going on?
Wait, wait.
Guys!
Guys, she's right there!
Oh, no.
No, please don't come in here.
Oh, she's just outside my door!
You go around her?
Oh, god.
Oh, god, I can't.
Oh, god, I can't!
Get away, get away!
Where are the cakes?
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
We made it through.
Get away from our heads.
Get away from our heads!
Okay, our heads are still here.
They're all still here.
That's good.
We had four, right?
I can't remember.
Wish we had so many.
I can't remember if we had four.
There's been so many.
Okay, four.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Hello?
Hello, everybody?
I'm split up from everybody.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, there you guys are!
Are you guys being chased?
There was no input on whether or not you guys were being chased.
Yeah, yeah.
I think she's gonna come out.
Oh, she came out!
She came out the other side!
Her eyes aren't red anymore.
You can stun her.
Okay.
Where is she?
She's like in front.
She's in front.
Have you guys seen any more heads?
I don't know where she is.
No, I'm wondering if the spawns are stuck behind actually burying bodies.
I think she's stupid.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, so like we have to... they spawn after?
Oh, we got her, we got her, we got her.
Okay, so like if they stop spawning, we might as well start burying.
Okay, let's bury them.
Alright, I'll put some cake down.
That might not be true, but there's nothing in the other world right now.
Alright.
Alright, all three of us, let's go!
We just need to get three heads on.
Alright, I got one.
I get this dude.
We got three heads and then let's bring... and then we can get Snuffy to bring a shovel.
Okay, where's Snuffy?
Wait, where is Snuffy?
What head do I even have on?
Okay, I don't know...
I think I have the gardener.
I have the gardener.
I don't know where this lady goes, but I'll figure it out.
Snuffy!
Okay, okay.
We have a shovel.
I have a shovel here.
I know where it is.
Here, here, here.
This is a shovel.
Right here.
Snuffy, you're a shovel duty.
Okay, let's find the head.
Mine's a gardener head.
Oh no, I found it.
I got one.
I got one here.
Bury time.
Do your thing, son.
Remember what I taught you, boy.
Remember what I taught you.
You're gonna dig those holes.
I'm so proud of you, son.
Snuffy's over here.
Wait, what's this, guys?
Wait.
What?
What is it?
What's that?
Oh, it's a key!
Oh, there it is!
Oh, um...
Uh-oh.
I got out you all.
Oh, God.
Right here.
Burry.
Just bury this guy.
Where did you put your head?
There's a...
He needs to be buried.
Snuffy, get over here.
Snuffy!
Get over here.
Bury her.
Right there, right there, right there.
We'll protect you.
Something's attacking me.
There's birds attacking me.
Oh, she took the head!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
We're gonna...
I'm so...
We're so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
No, I'm so sorry.
Son!
Son, pick me back up!
Thank you, son.
Oh, my God.
I knew you got this, boy.
I knew you were there for me, boy.
Bro, okay.
We can finally bury...
What the fuck are you laughing about?
That's the girl!
That's the girl from before!
Hold on to it.
Hold on to it for now.
Oh, we have the other head.
Come with me.
Come with me, Snuffy.
Okay.
No, she's not.
We gotta... Come in here, right here.
Just hurry!
Just...
Flashlight battery, guys.
Flashlight battery.
Watch out.
I have a battery.
There's a battery right here.
There's a battery right in front of you.
Run!
Run, Ike.
I won it.
Famous last words.
She was like, I won it.
No, it didn't break!
I tried so hard to warn her.
She was like, I won it.
Do you have the shovel?
I have it.
Okay, there we go.
Where am I getting beat up?
Oh, there he is.
I'll go save Snuffy.
Why are you attacking me?
Who's laughing?
Oh, I think that's us.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
No, that's my character celebrating because she's a freak.
She's here.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
She's here.
She's mad.
Oh, my God.
Give me.
Drop it.
Are you?
Get away from me!
Oh, there's my son over there.
There he is.
There's my boy.
We have four more to go.
Oh, God.
Yeah, we could just put this here then until...
Yeah.
No, but then she's going to get stronger.
So, we might as well just put that here for now until we have three more heads.
Oh, no.
She is definitely stronger.
Okay, we got to get our boy.
Oh, okay.
Boy!
My boy!
Don't worry.
Your daddies are here.
It's not aggro now.
Like father, like son.
I'm so proud of her.
Oh,
my God.
I was saying...
I have this.
Do we want to go bury it?
I think we got it.
We got it.
Like, no, just put it here until we get two more heads.
So, then we can do the three heads thing, strat again.
Okay, okay, okay.
She's definitely in that tunnel.
Oh, she's coming.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
She just said next time, fucker.
She's still coming.
Go to the other world.
Walk around.
Where's the medkits?
Oh, no, not another one.
I'm trying to find more medkits.
Nowhere is safe.
Wait a minute, that's two dead bodies.
I have medkit, I have medkit.
Come to me, children, I have medkit.
Who's more?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my
God, they harder.
I'm sorry, I had to choose.
I had to choose the child that was most resourceful.
Um...
What was that?
What was that sound?
Get to the other world, get to the other world.
I'm sorry.
We get dead again.
This is bullshit.
Oh, no.
You were supposed to be the chosen child.
Are you okay?
I found a head, I found a head, I found a head.
Oh, my God, I found a head.
Do healing items not spawn back?
Oh, you found a head?
Yeah, yeah, I found...
We found a head.
What are you talking about?
I was literally right in front of it.
I was trying to find a cake.
Oh, my God.
You...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I didn't mean any of that.
I'm just a little grouchy.
I'm just a little grouchy right now.
I found a head.
I found a head, I found a head.
I'm dead.
Goodbye.
It's up to me.
Oh, no.
Medkits...
Medkits don't respawn.
What are you doing?
It's up...
It's up to you, mid.
We're all dead.
We're all dead now.
It's up to you.
You got this.
We're gonna block your path.
We're gonna block...
We'll block her from killing you.
We'll form a human shield.
You walked into her.
What are you...
Oh, there's our dead bodies, guys.
There it is.
We got devoured.
Guys, we kind of got bodied.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
We didn't survive.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna turn off player collision.
No, I'm keeping player collision.
I'm turning off batteries and I'm turning off medkits.
Wait.
No, I think turning off batteries is bad because, like, our flashlight is still refilled.
But the batteries added more to it.
So, turning off batteries would be worse.
Oh, okay.
What medkit means, like, we don't have any meds at all?
Yeah, no, you want to keep those on.
Oh, okay, so everything is the same.
Alright, we can make it easier, by the way.
Okay.
We can make it.
I think I get it, right?
I think I get the hang of it now.
You got it, right?
You figured it out, boy.
We have the system now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we figured it out.
It just took a long time.
It just took multiple medkits.
Okay, alright guys, ready up.
I believe in us.
I'm so sorry.
I know this is way late, guys, but how is the audio?
I feel like I'm too loud, but don't think that I need to be louder.
I don't think they realized they could skip the cutscene.
So we can hear...
I can just hear Mint talking to herself in the other room.
Stuck in cutscene verse.
Mint, you can hit escape to skip the cutscene.
She can't hear, she has her AirPods on.
She has her AirPods on.
Press escape.
Hello?
Hey guys, I like how you guys watched the entire cutscene so we could hear you guys talk in the other world.
You were like, mushy mushy.
I like to be immersed.
I like to sympathize with the ghost.
It's on the same level as the game.
I know this has been late game, but is the volume okay, guys?
Your audio is all fucked, Doki.
That's why I'm asking.
Yeah, yeah, you can mute the jump.
I turned it off.
It was so loud.
Don't feel bad about it.
Alright, we figured out the system, guys.
Let's...
Let's get ready to do the fastest fucking run of our lives.
Yeah.
We gotta make sure we grab all the keys, though.
Wasn't there... this one spawned here.
It wasn't here originally.
Maybe... yeah, maybe it's different.
Maybe, like, it spawns more when we grab more keys.
Or grab more heads.
What?
Wait, the people?
The bodies?
Oh, you're right.
That's not where the chef is.
Oh, no.
That's the lady.
That's the disco lady.
Okay, that's the groom.
Okay, the groom's over here.
The groom's back there.
Flower girl.
Okay, red dress.
Alright, I'm ready.
Are you guys ready?
I'm so ready.
I believe in us.
Did we pour alcohol in there already?
Okay, you're pouring.
Alright, alright.
Not yet, until we start it.
Until you open... remember when you opened that door?
That's when it starts, man.
That's when...
Remember that first door you opened and then the lady started coming out?
Yeah, then I'll do it again.
This is why...
This is why we all die.
I think the moment we spawn the bride, the doors can be opened.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can't open anything, so we gotta go to the other world.
Don't worry, boy.
I got you.
I got you, boy.
Alright, let's go.
Where was the lady that you saw?
It has to be the same one, right?
Like, the same door?
Oh, there she is.
Through this door, right?
Yeah, it was through this door.
Yeah, yeah, son.
It's time.
It's time to meet that woman again.
Wait, I did this before, Ned.
It's time to meet her again.
Yeah, alright, daughter.
You ready for your woman time?
I'm not even fucking streaming!
It's time to be a woman.
Oh, that's what it feels like.
Yeah, I get jump scared.
You guys just have the lights turned on.
We gotta get keys now.
We gotta get keys.
Keys and heads.
The strats.
Maybe the key will... Maybe the key is found outside.
Because...
Oh, true!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When we picked it up.
Oh, there she is.
Alright, I got a cake.
Nice.
Okay, we need children's bedroom.
There's more head cake here.
Oh, hey, there's a bathroom we unlocked.
Oh, I got another... I got a painting room.
Oh, not painting room.
That's a place we haven't even seen before.
No, we have.
I've seen the painting room right now.
I got painting room key.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I need to open the painting room, though.
I know.
I saw it.
I was literally just there.
How do we get there?
I don't remember.
We got the dining room.
It's like back here, right?
Here, here, here, here.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Maybe we'll find a head.
No heads?
Head, head, head!
Pick it up, pick it up!
Come on, little boy.
Come on.
Come on, little guy.
Alright, nice.
We got one.
Alright, now I'll bring the head over to get cleansed.
Oh, if he doesn't eat it!
If he doesn't finish his job!
I'm gonna go clean it.
I'm cleaning the head.
Okay,
we're okay.
I'm just gonna clean the head first.
That's fine.
She's not aggro.
She's like calm.
Oh, he's looking at me.
He's fucking looking.
That's right.
Clean.
Get cleaned.
That's right.
Wait, I wonder if we don't do the...
Wait.
Oh, no.
He...
He's angry.
Okay, never mind.
I was gonna say...
Like, if we don't start... Oh, there's the chef.
If we don't start...
Like, burying heads on the first one...
Then, like, I'm thinking, like...
Maybe, like...
The crows won't come to get the heads.
But then... No, the crow can still be killed.
He was looking at that head.
He was looking at it.
It was, like, so juicy for him.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, cleanse, cleanse, cleanse.
Yeah.
That's fine.
The birds aren't super aggro.
They're not super aggro, so we're fine.
It's only at the...
After the...
After, like, we do more heads...
It starts getting weird.
I'll pour more alcohol.
I feel so.
They sell well, but they're not...
Like, they're not really aggro right now.
Because we haven't...
We haven't put them in anywhere.
Alright, I'm gonna see if I can find more heads for us.
You'll die by yourself forever.
What?
You'll be by...
Oh, hey, hey there.
Hi.
I'm trying to find more heads.
I have more cake.
Yum, yum, yum.
But I couldn't find anybody.
I just opened these doors...
Yeah, there's no heads in there.
What about here?
Oh, wait, there's a closet key.
Didn't you have a closet key?
Where the fuck are these heads?
Oh, hey, there's a pumpkin.
Wait, wait, there's a...
Did you guys have a... There's a closet right here.
Where's the closet key?
Somebody has it, I remember.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there it is!
Zen, come here!
Come on, boy!
Okay, alright, sure.
Put it closer, I guess.
And I'll do it again.
I got the head again.
Alright, is there alcohol in there?
I don't even know.
Wait, there's no alcohol in here.
How am I supposed to scrub the head?
I can't even scrub the head!
Guys!
I need alcohol!
But, like, not for drinking.
It's for cleaning reasons.
Oh, there's one right here.
Guys, I need...
Someone pick an alcohol for me.
Yeah, it's on the other side.
It's right here.
Yeah, I got it.
I can't clean it.
Okay.
It's for cleaning, guys.
I don't have a problem.
Alright.
Until now.
We will be the first VTubers who beat this game.
It's true.
Okay, I'm here waterboarding the head now.
Tell us where all the other heads are.
How do we put it face down?
Tell us where all the heads are!
There's a little baby head!
Yeah, he's the ring boy.
I feel like this looks like...
You know how in Minecraft, you can, like...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Did you find a head, boy?
That's fine.
It's just one guy.
Yeah, but he's, like, super...
They're super calm for now.
The more heads we bury, the more aggro they get.
Yeah, the more crazy they get.
Alright, we just need...
We just need to find another...
Do you think we'll be able to find more heads, or is that it for now?
I'm not sure.
We need to find the place to bury the shovel first.
Which way?
It was this way, outside here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we should be able to have a shovel, like...
Yeah, here.
We'll find more alcohol, just in case.
Oh, there's a shovel!
I found a shovel!
I found a shovel.
Priest.
A little bit of priest.
I'm stuck.
Okay.
That's nice, Sweeney Todd.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Okay, where is...
Okay, that's the chef.
Now I know where the chef is.
Oh, there's more medkits here.
There's a maid.
I found the maid!
Oh, there's a key!
I have the children's bedroom!
Get a key just in time.
Just in case.
Okay.
The children's bedroom has two doors.
So make sure you get both of them.
What are you looking at?
Yeah, I see you.
Okay.
That's literally you.
Yeah, but there can only be one.
Okay, I got this.
Wait, where's the other children's bedroom?
Right here.
Oh, there it is.
Is there a head in here?
Oh, there's a head here!
There's a head here.
Oh, I got him.
Please.
Alright, let's go clean it.
Yoink.
Alright, time to clean.
Clean, clean, clean.
I don't remember.
We have five heads now.
Alright.
Alright, clean time.
Where are the other heads?
Tell me the information.
Where are they?
Alright, I got an old man.
Oh, I got the priest.
Yeah, yeah, he's new.
Alright, do you think we can find more heads?
Or is that it?
No, we did.
We just unlocked it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So I feel like...
Oh my God, your cake is so extra moldy.
I feel like we should get five more alcohol and put it down here then.
Just in case.
Lime, are you okay?
Lime?
Lime, are you... Lime, just talk to me.
Yes, yes, I'm here.
I wasn't disassociating myself.
Oh my God.
Oh.
What was the plan?
Are we burying as many heads as possible?
We are trying to...
We're gonna go find all the alcohol.
We're trying to stockpile the alcohol, just in case.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure.
Oh, we could.
Yeah, I think we're fine.
Okay, I got some alcohol here.
Okay, I'm gonna put more here.
Alcohol downstairs.
Okay, I got more alcohol.
We can also stockpile medkits too.
I have alcohol here.
Alright, I mean we have three, that should be...
It's not enough, but like...
Yeah, it should be good.
One, two, three, four, five.
We need two more, I guess?
I guess, yeah.
I think that's fine, right?
For now.
Oh wait, then there's also...
This one's filled, so...
Yeah, I think we just need one more.
We just need one more, yeah.
This is the strat.
Oh, there's one right here!
He left it here.
I think they just found it and left it here for us.
Oh, I see you.
You wanted out those heads.
That's fucking right.
Alright, here's the strat!
It's time!
It's time, everybody!
Grab a head!
I got the shovel.
Wait, where's Lime?
Okay, I got...
Should we shovel them or just put the heads down?
I don't know.
I feel like the crows are gonna...
There's not a lot of crows right now, though.
But there's not a lot of crows right now.
But we do need to put at least one hat.
Yeah, that's true.
I feel like we should just put them on now.
I feel we should get the other shovel...
and then one person puts it on...
and the other person...
Okay.
Alright, let's...
I think there's only one shovel, isn't there?
Okay.
Lime, we're ready!
We're ready to bury some heads!
Grab a head!
Mine's a priest.
Alright, let's go.
Mine's a gigachat, I guess?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, is that the groom?
Or is that a different one?
It looks totally different.
Alright, let's figure it out.
Come on, let's go.
Okay.
Guess who?
Do you have facial hair?
Alright.
There's a medkit right here, by the way.
Okay, that's a lady.
That's a lady over there.
Oh no, that's a little boy.
That's...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is there bodies here?
That's a flower girl.
That's a red lady.
I don't think that's...
There's no more here, right?
No, it's not this side.
I think it's at the other side.
It's the other side.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
that's the chef.
Yeah.
I think it's at the wedding reception, I think.
That's the chef, that's the chef.
So it's the wedding...
We have to find the...
It has to be the wedding area.
Maybe this one?
This one right here?
Oh no, that's my...
That's my guy?
No, this guy right here.
Maybe this guy.
No, my guy is the priest.
Right here.
Yeah, we found your guy.
I think we found your guy.
We found your guy.
I think it's here.
It is a groom.
It's not this guy?
Oh, okay.
Should we start burying?
Alright.
Go, go, go, go!
Snuffy, it's your turn!
Snuffy!
This is what you've been training for, boy.
This is it.
I'm so proud of you.
Snuffy, come here!
Come here, come here, come here!
Priest, priest!
Priest, priest, priest!
Uh-oh.
We can stun her though.
Yeah, for now, yeah.
Alright, come here, come here, boy!
Come on!
No, you've got your head.
You've still got your head.
You've got your head, you've got your head.
Oh, okay.
Wait, why did I see it on the side?
It flew around the screen a little bit.
It was weird.
Yeah, yeah, the crow was about to grab it.
Where's the red...
Okay, I grabbed the medkit for now too.
Where's the...
Okay, where's the red...
I don't remember where the...
Right here, right here, right here, right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, if I see her, I'll get her.
I got my guns.
I'm burying you.
I'm ready.
She's here, she's here, she's here!
Oh, just kidding.
We got you.
Alright, nice!
She's still pissed, she's still pissed.
Run!
Wait, she's got red eyes, you guys.
She's got...
Run, run, run, run, run, run!
I'm ready!
Wait, did she get somebody?
I think she got mid, I think she got mid.
I think she got mid.
I gotta go to the other world.
Mid, I'm coming!
Oh, shit!
Okay, not yet, not yet!
I got stuck!
But now I am!
I got stuck, but here I am!
What the fuck happened?
Oh, there's a head, there's a head!
We have a head!
There's a head right here!
We gotta get a cake!
Where's the cake when you need one?
Guys, we need a cake!
Oh my god, that scared the shit out of me.
I have cake, I have cake, I have cake!
Where's the bot head?
I have a cake.
Oh, there he is!
Come on!
Here he comes!
Hello there, little guy!
Oh, he's in the ghost world.
There you go, I got him.
Okay, okay.
This is a team game!
Alright, I'll go wash the head.
We need to find the other shovel.
I think there's only one shovel.
No, there's definitely two.
I don't know where the other shovel is.
Do we want to bury the other two heads?
There's two more.
I have one as well, I have one, so we all have three.
So we can bury the next wave.
We'll bury the next wave of heads.
It's faster than how fast you run.
It sucks.
I'm wondering if we're supposed to stun her, then turn our flashlights off and hide or something.
I don't know.
I think we just keep...
Nice, alright.
I have...
Okay, did someone take the baby head?
I have the maid.
I'm putting porn alcohol in now.
Why can't I pick your rat off the floor and sell them?
Yeah, I have the maid, you have the chef.
Alright, let's go!
It's time!
Let's go, let's go!
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
We gotta go.
I think we still gotta go, though.
But, like, what do we...
Yeah, we gotta go.
No, I think she just gets angry, you know?
Every so often.
Yeah.
It's a little temper tantrum.
She just gets angry sometimes.
Oh, ouch!
I got you, I got you.
Okay, I have...
At least she's...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, nice.
I have...
I have the maid.
Oh no, she's dead.
Snuffy's dead.
Alright, let's just bury...
Wait, Snuffy has the...
Snuffy has the shovel!
Oh no!
Wait, I have this guy, I think.
Yeah, just put that guy in and grab the shovel.
I can...
I'll guard the...
Yeah, I'll guard the body.
Just get the shovel.
Oh, it's Snuffy.
Alright.
Wait, okay, um...
I have medkit, I have medkit!
Please, please.
She's gonna come over, I'm just gonna warn you.
I'm just gonna...
I have the maid!
Oh, she's gonna come over.
I have the maid, I have the maid, I have the maid!
Yeah, where's the maid?
I think it's on...
I think the maid is on the...
The maid is on the other side, right?
Okay.
Just run.
I have the maid!
Wait, who's this?
A child.
Yeah.
She's coming, she's behind you!
I think the maid was, like, here.
Yeah, yeah, got it, got it, got it.
Okay.
She has red eyes!
It's okay.
It's okay, I'll finish the job.
I'll finish the job.
Don't worry.
I'll do it for you.
Alright, let's go!
She's gonna be angry, though.
She's gonna be angry now, but I got a medkit.
Somebody pick up the shovel!
Uh-oh.
Wait, what's the other head?
Who has the other head?
I don't know who has the other head!
What's the last head?
Mint, get over here!
Mint, keep crawling!
Get your lazy ass over here, Mint!
Mint, I see you walking away!
Mint, I can't go there!
I need you to come here!
She's lying!
Oh, it doesn't stop her.
It doesn't stop her.
She's still angry.
Oh, god.
No, no, I'm dead!
I'm dead!
She has red eyes!
Oh, I have a head on me.
I have a head on me!
I have a head!
I have a head right here!
What the fuck, Lime?!
There's a head here.
Yeah, yeah.
Right here, right here.
He's just chilling.
Oh, I see him.
Was I yelling at Lime?
Who the fuck was I yelling at?
Oh, it was Lime.
I thought it was you.
Because I was yelling at somebody to crawl over.
Oh, watch me get this head in front of you.
You can't grab it.
Fuck you.
Let's see if she's dead.
Let's see.
I heard it.
Uh-oh.
Down I go.
Off I go into the light.
Hey, you guys got a head?
Oh, hi.
Oh, nice.
I got you.
I just got the water girl.
Flower girl?
Yeah, I'll put the alcohol back in there.
I saw a bird carrying a head.
Oh.
That could be the ring boy, right?
Because we didn't do the ring boy.
No, we did do the ring boy.
Who the fuck did we not do?
What?
I think it was the chef.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I think somebody took the chef.
The crow took the chef.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Fuck your boy.
Water girl.
Wait, where's the chef?
Right here, right here.
Um, you think we can do it?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Go back, go back, go back, go back.
Go back, go back, go back.
I saw them chasing Lyman and Stuffy.
I saw them chasing.
I saw...
If we have to wait out, we gotta go.
Yeah, but we gotta wait for them to chase them and then we'll go.
Okay.
We can always adopt new children.
No.
Oh.
Yeah?
You wanna go back out?
Okay, she's gone.
Okay, nice.
Know what?
Um...
Me too, I think so too.
I think she is...
Okay.
Right here.
I...
Okay.
Back into the spirit world I go.
The last spot.
Right here.
Right fucking here.
Yep, it's right here.
Guys, we're running out of bed.
Kids, guys.
Oh, there's a head.
Okay, I'll look at you.
There's the head right here.
I see you.
Come on.
As long as I'm next to the head.
There's two heads up here.
There's two heads.
That's seven, eight.
Nine, there's two more.
Okay, we're missing two.
There's two heads up here.
Please, somebody go to the other world.
There's two heads.
Where did the other head go?
Okay.
I need to go to that window, that mirror.
Tell the whole world that there's two heads and then come back.
Where are they?
Oh.
There's one, two.
One, two.
Oh, there's the other head.
There she is.
There she goes.
I think there's only two bedkits left.
Oh my God.
Guys, I don't know if we're gonna make it.
Where is everyone?
Where did everyone go?
Where is everybody?
Where are you guys?
Guys!
I found two heads.
Upstairs.
Yeah, upstairs.
Oh my God!
Let me go grab some.
Okay.
Who has the other shovel?
Who has the shovel?
I don't know.
Wait, weren't you holding a head earlier?
She's coming for you.
Alright, let's figure out who she's coming for.
Alright, let's fucking try and test it out.
I'm gonna shut the door.
Okay, I'm gonna shut this other door.
Alright.
Come on in, boy.
Maybe it was a mistake.
Wait, I thought you were holding a head earlier.
What were you holding on?
It's right by the altar.
The shovel is right by the altar outside.
That's where I died.
Okay, okay.
Should we go?
Yeah, let's go.
She's not mad anymore.
She's not?
That's good.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Yeah, yeah, where's the... Okay, I'm trying to find the shovel that you threw away.
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
I found the shovel!
There's a crew!
No.
Oh no.
Snuffy, let me know if she's coming for me!
Wait, where did Snuffy go?
Oh no.
Guys, I don't know.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna win this.
Wait, how did the door open?
How did the door open by itself?
Who's out there?
Oh my god.
Oh, now there's two.
There's two.
Now there's two.
Oh no, now it's me and Mint!
Oh no!
And now there were two.
I have the shovel!
You have the head?
I have the shovel, Mint!
Oh, she's coming by you!
Okay, I closed the door.
Do you guys know where the medkits are?
No, I got you!
I got you!
Please!
Mint!
I'm not done yet!
No!
Mint, please!
No.
No!
I'm done!
I'm gonna die to Mint!
Oh my god.
We have nothing!
We have no medkits!
No!
Bodyblocker!
Crows!
The crows!
They don't stop!
No!
The crows!
I died to the crows!
No!
Oh my god.
Oh, dang it.
I died to the crows!
I couldn't...
Oh my god.
No!
No, that's not true!
I died to the crows!
I died a different way!
I couldn't!
There was nothing I could do!
My...
I couldn't kill the crows, so I kept I kept fucking flashing them!
Yeah.
And she even did the thing like, I'll get you next time, so I was like, ooh, I'm safe.
And her eyes were red, so it didn't really look like she wasn't gonna keep going, but she was just like, actually, bye.
She was red on my screen, so I think it's also kinda buggy.
Oh my god.
You know what?
We did really well, guys.
I think we did...
I think we did really well.
I think we did as well as we could.
We just didn't have any perks, so you can't blame us.
We just didn't have any perks.
Yeah.
I only just got a perk now.
Oh, right.
There's perks in this game.
Right.
I still can't actually do anything with the perks.
It's greyed out.
Yeah, it's greyed out for me.
Actually, I was trying to click on it.
It wasn't letting me.
Yeah, I don't think we have perks.
Oh, wait.
I turned it on.
Now we have perks.
I'm gonna spend my perk on an emote instead.
Good idea.
Oh my god.
You literally can have faster movement if you...
This is...
This is actually crying to win.
You can move faster when getting chased by the demon.
Fast worker?
And you have... You're faster.
You're faster when you're carrying ritual items.
Oh my god.
This is...
This is all about the grind.
This is all...
Wait, there's hiding spots?
There was no hiding spots.
It's like UV charge reject... Oh, it's for the spider lady.
Cause the fucking manor did not have hiding spots for sure.
Uh...
Yeah, maybe the other maps make more sense and we accidentally just went in on like the equivalent of level 15 Pico Park or something.
Oh my god.
Do you remember some of the maps had like closets you could hide in?
No, it doesn't.
That's why I'm saying the spider.
The spider has like...
Yeah, but you were saying... People were saying the manor was like different from how they usually do.
So I think they got rid of the hiding spots for the manor.
I don't know why.
That's some sick, cruel joke.
It was too easy.
That's some sick fucking joke.
For getting rid of the hiding spots.
It was not easy.
I remember struggling so hard on the end.
I remember the fucking spiders.
Yeah, I know.
What's the lore with that?
There's a giant spider lady that's gonna fucking eat you and then instead of crows, it's other spiders that try to attack your ankles.
They like, try to gobble your ankles.
Honestly, that kind of sounds fun for next time, maybe.
Yeah, Lime is just wants to fucking pass out right now.
I mean, if we can do it this time, I'm so ready.
No, I could fail.
I was like, Lime, are you okay?
You just stare out into the space and I'm like, she is not okay.
She is not okay.
I'm trying.
I'm trying really hard to be okay.
I don't know.
No, it's okay.
I like how Lime bought this movement speed increase perk already.
She just...
I'm ready to go fucking fast.
Yeah, she already bought the movement speed after getting fucked over by the bride because we were too slow.
I know what I'm gonna buy then.
What are you buying?
You can't use, you can't use your fucking perks to buy emotes.
Oh my god, I can flex.
Oh my god, do you see that?
No, no, no.
Movement speed increased by 25% when pursued by a Zazel.
Oh, you can.
Pursued by a Zazel?
Which one is a Zazel?
Oh, that's the bride.
What the fuck emote did you buy?
What did you...
I bought finger guns.
Oh my god.
How do you do emotes?
You have to get in game for that.
Oh, I see the finger gun.
This is the one I bought, right?
I see it.
I see the finger gun.
How do I buy them?
You have to scroll down to the emote, you go to outfits.
And then, no, you go to outfits and then you scroll all the way down for the perks.
Like, you can use your perk talismans to buy it.
The other one.
Wait, so there was a finger gun that I didn't need to buy.
Oh, this one, yeah.
Oh, I got the draw gun.
Oh, you didn't buy the finger gun?
You have to win a game in a hard mode as Sam.
Oh my god.
Nevermind, I hate this game.
Yeah, I don't think we can...
We can barely do normal, guys.
We can barely...
GG's, though.
I had fun.
GG's.
I had a lot of fun.
Thank you.
I'm sorry we're so out of it.
No, it's alright.
You had a long day.
It was super cozy, yeah.
Thank you guys for inviting me.
Thanks for the nice family vacation, guys.
I had a great time.
Yeah, we had a great time.
I forgot I left a lot of them.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay, next time...
The voices, they're gone.
By the way, Min, you're muted.
You're muted, so we can't hear you.
Bless me with my voice.
Oh, and then Lime is still disassociated, so she's deafened.
She's just staring at her monitor.
And Lime...
Undeafened.
Let her sleep.
It's okay.
I thought you guys just ditched me.
No!
The voices were echoing, so we were like...
No, I was deafened, and I just completely forgot we were in Discord.
I guess that's it.
I guess they just left everyone.
That was fun.
Yeah, it was fun.
It's okay.
Yeah, no, next time, we just gamer it.
And we win.
Easy peasy.
Spiders.
I'm ready to face the spiders.
Oh, the spiders.
Oh my gosh, we just have a whole devour marathon.
A whole devour marathon where we never beat the game.
We just lose over and over again.
We always die.
We can YouTube the ending of someone who bought all the perks.
I wish I knew.
I would've just bought them to start with.
And you have to earn the little things.
You can't pay to win perks.
You actually have to earn them through tier playing.
So they hate fun.
They really do.
That's why they want us to play.
So we keep having fun.
That's the whole point.
I wish I could hit that woman with a shovel.
You can say doki.
Yeah, you can say it.
I've just encountered so many croquis.
I deserved it.
GG's guys.
I had a great time.
Thank you for playing.
Let's do it again next time.
Bye-bye.
I'll see you...
Oh, okay.
I thought Min wanted to stay for an extra second or something.
She didn't instantly.
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
It was a double stream.
So I'm going to...
I'm going to pass out now.
I'm going to grab some food.
I need to walk, dad.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
I'm so sorry for the...
How loud the jump scares were.
We tried our best.
We tried.
I'm so sorry.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye.